&gt;&gt; Did you get y equals negative 4 for the first answer, and x equals 3 for the
second answer? If so, way to go! Let's see how we got those answers. Similar to
the last practice problems that we did, for the first problem we know that a
slope of 0 means a horizontal line, and a horizontal line looks like this. And
we know the equation is going to be y equals sum constant. If I put a point on
the line, 3 negative 4. I know that, no matter what x equals, y is always going
to equal negative 4. Which is why we get the equation, y equals negative 4. For
the second problem, the key here is the undefined slope. We know that undefined
slope means its a vertical line. And we know a vertical line looks like that,
and I also know the equation of a vertical line is x equals a constant. When I
plot the point on my vertical line, 3 negative 4, I can see that no matter what
the value of y is, the x value always stays at 3. So, the equation is x equals
negative 3.